Welcome all millions of new subscribers that don't want T-Series to win.
To my Closet Review! (claps) (claps).
Closet Review.
What's inside Felix's closet?
"Pewdiepie, he uploads gaming videos right?"
Just kidding!
Closet Review!
So, this is uh, something that has been requested by maybe two or three people.
I did a closet video uh, a few years back. And here we are, finally!
The thing that everyone has been waiting for!
Closet tour part two.
Can we get some closet tour part two hype in the chat, guys?
Are you zooming in on my face?
Oh yeah!
Okay, first off. As you noticed - new closet.
Smash like if you think it's a cool closet.
Second of all, I've been kind of scared to make this video because of, uh -
I said a lot of stuff that I regret in that video. A lot of preachy... preachy stuff about -
No, I - I wouldn't spend money on like this, that's so dumb, and here I am.
I spend money on everything. I'm sorry.
First of all, this is a no judgement zone, okay?
So no one can judge me. I'm looking at you.
You cannot judge me, okay?
Listen, I stopped drinking and I don't spend money on whiskey anymore.
What am I gonna spend YouTube money on?
*Da na na naaaaaa*
Wow!
"What a diverse and nice closet," is your immediate thought, isn't it?
Wow, he sure likes black doesn't he?
(claps) (claps) Closet review.
Where do I begin?
Marzia: That one.
Which one?
Marzia: The sleeves and the, uh yeah
This one.
This is the, uh, latest one I bought.
It's, uh... this is a problem when you have black clothing and pugs
I still wear it for some reason. It's from... Jyunji
I think it's Japanese.
I don't know.
You'll probably notice that most of my items are very oversized
I really like this one.
It's a really cool fit.
Look guys, it's fake. It's not actually layered.
That's fashion.
You see this I'm wearing? That's fashion.
What purpose does it have? Absolutely nothing.
That's. Fashion.
Smash like.
I really like, uh,  aheh... oversized clothing *laughs*
Here's another oversized
This is from Gasha
Gasha's one of my favorite brands.
You probably -  for those of you who know the brand, it's a really cool Russian designer
He really brings back the... the feeling of being homeless in Russia, but paying hundreds of dollars to have the look
🤰😡Is that a good explanation?🤰😡
I really love this one.
It's such a good fit.
It has got these baggy arms as well.
I like hoodies, okay? I kinda have a problem with hoodies.
One of my more recent favorite brands is, uh, a Japanese brand.
Marzia got me this for a video
🤰😡Cause, you were gonna dress me, right?🤰😡
Marzia: Mhmm
And you got me this on sale
🤰😡Please don't judge me, how much money I spend on clothes, okay?🤰😡
I'm not trying to flex. This is just - I have a problem.
This is sad is what I'm saying.
But I love Caya - Caven't? I don't know how to pronounce it.
Every time I say a brand wrong, it's like *chuckles*
*cough*
*in French accent*
It's Cavaughnt
It's Fraunch
No, it's Japanese. It's a super cool brand.
Uh, if you guys wanna get some pieces, follow them on Twitter.
Cuz, uh, that's how you get the hot stuff.
This is... Kevin Bousua
This is so cringy *laughs*
I freaking love it.
And they have this one as well.
I love this shirt.
A lot of fashion now is neon, this type of green. Kinda like... I don't know how to des - explain it. Computer-ishy?
That's what I try to do with Pew News the merch.
But, I don't think anyone cares *laughs*
Seriously, they have the coolest designs.
I just see their, uh, I see everything from them, and I'm like "I want it."
I want it ALL!
I feel like my, uh, opinion about clothing has changed a lot with...
It's nice to own some nicer things, is what I'm saying.
*Maya barks*
Treat yourself.
I guess before, I would buy *bark* - Maya please, I'm talking about fashion 'ere.
*bark* Before I would buy maybe one cheap item and I would wear it once and then it's like "I don't really care about even making it nice"
But you buy nicer pieces of clothing *bark* and those filled with hair.
You kinda want to take care of it more.
That's how I feel like.
Uhhhh, my mom bought me this
I guess vests were cool for a while but it didn't last long *laughs*
Maybe they'll come back.
*zip*
I don't think anyone wears vests
It was one of those fads that, if you fell for it, you're kinda a loser.
But thanks Mom, anyway.
🤰😡I really like it anyway. I don't care, alright?🤰😡
That's a nice vest, man.
🤰😡Did your mom buy it?🤰😡
YEAH SHE DID.
Shut up!
I - and she's lovely.
I bet you wish your mom bought you clothes
Another brand I really like is...  Adder
Adher?
Adherr.
This is a Korean brand,  I think? 🤰😡I'm not sure.
They're doing a collection that's - it's kinda  old computer...
I guess like a lot of fashion now is retro.
Subtle retro.
Kinda like a throwback to the 90's.
If you check out this brand, it's very meme-y
It's kinda like, uh, everyone's wearing these silly sunglasses
Doesn't take itself kinda seriously, but still is edgy
at the same time in, uh, a weird way.
You like this one?
Marzia: Mmhmm
It's got a good fit to it too. And if you want a unique piece...
You kinda have to pay a bit more.
Which is bit st - uh, it's annoying.
I wish I had cheaper brands to actually recommend.
One thing that I really like to do is layer sweaters with a polo shirt or something like that.
This is also Adder.
It's got a weird, like YouTube logo on it, it's kinda strange.
But it looks cool when you layer it. It really -
I like doing that a lot.
I had one of the - in my Bitch Lasagna video I had a layered polo shirt underneath
And, uhh, *ha ha* I loved that polo shirt so much.
I thought it looked so cool to layer it. And I was like "Ah this is so dope"
I found a thing that is, like, cool, and not a lot of people have it, and this is mine
And, uhh, I washed it. And it shrank. *laughs*
And it cost FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS *laughs*
Another great brand that I like is Daily Paper.
Ummm... I think they're based in Amsterdam.
Umm, but they focus on kinda African culture.
Africa?!🤰😡
But they're really cool. I like this cause, it's finally not a black sweater in my collection.
I'll take it!
It looks good.
They also have really neat looking pants.
If you guys are looking for some pants, I recommend, uh, Daily Paper
Great fabric, great fit. All their pants they have are really good.
🤰😡They're kinda cool too, right?🤰😡
Speaking of pants - these are also pretty cool.
This, uh, Japanese brand called, uh, Maha- Maharishi
🤰😡Uh, which is supposed to be... military design?🤰😡
They did a collection with, uh, censorship in the media.
And I thought that was interesting.
They got like these lil things you tie around your legs as well.
It's kinda cute.
Any small stuff like that, you know. You wanna stand out a bit. You're like "Yeah I'll tie - I'll tie a little thing there
Or if you're feeling extra fancy, you'll let 'em loose.
You let 'em rip.
But that's if you're an absolute mad lad.
Also!
Y3 very cool belt.
It stands out. I think it's small details and small accessories that really makes your outfit look so much more.
It's - uh, I'm stating the obvious here, but
It's just a - It's one of those things that I didn't used to care about, but I really enjoy trying out different things
I guess cause a lot of people have been asking about this sweater... it's really cool.
🤰😡A4?🤰😡
It's a - I know it's collaboration. Yeah. It's Kappa and A4.
Bought it in Japan!
Really, my addiction with fashion started in Japan
Cause everyone was - if you've ever been to Tokyo, everyone just dresses so freely
People just wear whatever they want and they are not being judged.
I really love that. I really miss that, just going outside and...
Wearing whatever you feel like and just, embracing that. It's really fun.
So last video I mentioned my favorite sweater was this one.
Cause it's very oversized.
But, uh, if you think this is oversized... you ain't seen nothing yet
Cause everything is just getting super sized.
You can't even tell what's a joke sometimes anymore. This is Venmoss, it's no big deal.
It's whatever.
Uhhh, it's inside out. It's pretty cool. I really like it.
They always do such crazy things! An inside out sweater!
🤰😡What are they gonna do next?🤰😡
🤰😡A shirt on top of a shirt?🤰😡
That's crazy!🤰😡
Clothes are just getting bigger and bigger.
Maybe I'm just shrinking
I love this thing
It's a bag from Alex. Alex is one of my favorite brands
I know it's not called Alex anymore but like I can't be bothered.
I always wear this and people are like "What is that?" and I'm like "It's fashion b*tch! What the f*ck do you- " *laughs*
🤰😡Where else am I going to keep my keys?🤰😡
🤰😡How fast can you grab your keys?🤰😡
I thought you always catch this
What are you doing?!🤰😡
Marzia: *laughs*
Marzia: Do it again! Do it again!🤰😡
Look at that! Marzia has a talent.
So black pants, black hoodies,
Felix, wow, this is a really interesting, versatile closet. I really enjoy it.
Alright.
Well, how about...
Black caps everybody!🤰😡
🤰😡You want some black caps?🤰😡
Oh yeah, this is uh *hahaha*
I love this.
Listen, you will never understand the power, unless you have this.
The power of wearing a Saturday hat.
On a Saturday.
Here's one of those things you buy online and you're like "Why did I buy that" *laughs*
🤰😡Cool. How do I wear this?🤰😡 Someone tell me. I love retaps but what the h*ll is this?🤰😡
We got the Suka Blyat
Wakdonalds
Time to respect wammen.
Tsuki.
Caven.
Sesh.
Wakdonalds.
Pew News.
Shoutout to Tsuki!
Sorry Tsuki but the most important of all...
The Gucci face mask.
If you don't have one of these in your closet,  then What. Are. You. Doing?
You're not fashioned, unless you own one of these.
Let's move on to uhh, accessories.
I also have these sunglasses.
I wore these for my McDonalds or Wakdonalds I mean sorry, don't sue me please. That was a joke.
A lot of people have been asking about the sunglasses I had in Bitch Lasagna.
Uhh, they're Swedish. They're called Command I think.
I'll link them if you guys are interested.
There's this Instagram blog that every time I wear a new outfit, they figure out where I got the clothes from. And I'm always so amazed that they actually found it.
But one of the few things they haven't found out was the glasses, so there you go.
No one cares. Moving on.
🤰😡What else do we got?🤰😡
🤰😡What the hell are you doing?🤰😡
We also have Tsuki! I love this one.
It's so cool
🤰😡Do you guys like it?🤰😡
Tsuki's selling out fast
Wakdonalds
I love this one
I had a lot of fun making this
I finally made, uh, the belt fit. *laughs*
The two hundred - I bought this belt for two hundred pounds *laughs*
And I could not fit it through any pants.
But, I managed.
🤰😡Okay?🤰😡 You just need a lot of time. And a lot of patience.
And you can make it happen. But, they're staying on these pants. I'm never taking them off.
🤰😡That's right, I have about fifty pairs of black pants. What are you gonna do?🤰😡 Judge me?🤰😡
Judge free zone. You can't do that here.
Marzia posted wearing one of these.  And they liked it. But I wear them ALL the time and they NEVER like it
What the frick!
It's a cool brand. I like Heron Preston.
I like oversized hoodies. Is anyone surprised?
What else do we got?
One thing that I said in my closet video that everyone's been giving me sh*t for...
Which is the fact that I - I said like "Oh yeah, I like to have like a lot of watches
Cause then - a lot of cheap ones, cause then I can just like keep changing them cause I always get bored
That's what I said. I never wear these anymore *laughs*
The thing is, I bought this, uh, this watch
It's not like CRAZY expensive, but it's still an expensive watch
And I bought it because, uh, when I proposed to Marzia, you got a ring. And I'm like "Well, what do I get?"
And everyone's always said "Oh, if you're gonna buy a watch, you should buy it for an occasion."
And I thought okay what better occasion to buy a watch then, then our engagement.
So that's why I got this Rolex.
I really love it.
It really changed my whole opinion on watches cause I -  I usually didn't used to get it.
I was like why f*ck would you spend so much money on a watch? That's just stupid.
Uhhh, preachy moment incoming!🤰😡
The reason I like it so much is cause  I think with fashion and clothes and accessories and all this stuff in general,
It's always so fast.
I pretty much don't wear most of the stuff that I had from a year ago and..
I - I love the fact that I have one item that I'm always gonna have.
Cause it's associated with some - some, a memory.
So this watch will always have a meaning to me.
And that's why I really like it. Obviously, it doesn't have to be expensive to do that.
But also the fact that it will last you a lifetime.
Which makes the difference
Please don't hate me okay I changed my mind *laughs*
I also have this
This is my wallet, it's kinda cool.
It's a good way to make sure that you die, in case...
🤰😡Just a - spice up your life a lil bit, you know?🤰😡 Why not make sure that you could possibly get stuck into something?🤰😡
🤰😡Seems like a great idea, right?🤰😡
Hey! Accessorize guys!🤰😡
You have to learn to accessorize.
Shoe time!🤰😡
So, in my video with Dave and, and Joel they made fun of me for having big shoes.
Joel: You should see the shoes Felix wears every day
Dave: *Laughs*
Joel: They're like this big
Dave: Proper platforms
Felix: They're not that big!
But they're not THAT big *laughs*
These are a Swedish brand called Eytys
I love these shoes
I wanted to buy shoes with big soles because I - I know what's gonna be hip
I know what's gonna be trendy
And I was like
Big shoes.
It's popping.
I wanna find a pair, but I could not find one I liked
Eytys dropped these and I was just like bam
I'm buying these. Epic style.
I realize it's kinda pathetic.
I'm just trying to hide the fact that I'm a man-let
But they look so good!🤰😡
🤰😡What're those guys?!🤰
🤰😡Oh, you like these pants that I'm wearing?🤰😡
That's right. Buy cargo pants right now. Super hit
Super lit
What're you doing if you're not wearing pants that doesn't at least have four pockets?
🤰😡 Then what's the point? 🤰😡
🤰😡Huh?🤰😡
You can't do this.
These are Alex pants. It's no big deal.
I don't really look at brands, I'm not really brand conscious.
I just buy what I like.
These are Alex pants by the way.
And finally, this is my jacket
I got it in Japan. They have yen in Japan and I didn't really figure - I didn't realize how much it cost.
I remember they told me the price and I was just like "Oh, sure"
I'll buy it. But I'm actually really glad I got it. I - I actually love it.
It's a really cool jacket.
It's kinda another meme, like it's so oversized.
If you wear this, you would just disappear.
I think it's cool okay? I don't care. Judgement free zone.
Awhile back when, uh,  the triple S Balenciagas were super popular
I wanted to buy them, but I also thought I just couldn't get myself to do it cause I was like "No, everyone has triple S and I wanted to be different."
So I bought these instead.
Which I never wear *laughs*
Because why did I buy expensive white shoes?
🤰😡What the hell was I thinking?🤰😡
You walk on these all the time anytime -
Marzia: What?!
Anytime I wear these when I'm out with Marzia I just have to keep, like, a distance from her to make sure..
That no one steps on these
And if we're at a restaurant with other people and someone accidentally touch your shoe, which happens you know..
And they go "Ah, I'm sorry"
And I go "Yeah, that's fine."
But inside I'm like "You f*cking b*tch"
What are you - these are Balenciagas!🤰😡
SoI just end up not wearing them.
Great purchase. Great story. I know.
🤰😡Hasn't this been a great time?🤰😡
I had fun.
Look how white these shoes are though. Honestly, like..
I did a good job
That was fashion closet tour.
Welcome to my closet, see you next year!🤰😡
Bye bye!🤰😡
Smash like and subscribe!🤰😡
So I can beat T series. This was my secret Plan B that I've been talking about
Brofist!🤰😡
*Suspenseful Music*
*Bang*
🤰😡*Bang*
*Sad Music*